these
are the two teeth marks of a leopard
this is quite a reality check these
hills
are filled with lethal predators
and i run the risk of winding up like
this poor goat
in some of the most inhospitable places
on earth
tribal people have survived against the
odds for thousands
of years i'm hazen audell
survival instructor and wilderness guide
i want to learn from the masters so i'm
traveling to some of the most remote
corners of the globe
to take on the toughest tribal
challenges
to succeed i must survive the tribe
these arrows have got to count amazing
absolutely amazing
this time i'm with the samburu a herding
tribe whose lives traditionally depend
on cattle
[Music]
a complete survival kit the cow can
provide
all the food these warriors need milk
meat and blood
the samburu live in an arid region of
equatorial kenya
it's a varied landscape from mountain
ranges to scrub
and desert plains but it's all tough
after three days of traveling i reach an
isolated village
this is my introduction to one of
africa's most formidable tribes
[Music]
the look that these people have the way
they look at you and how tall they are
it is intimidating these are the guys
that are going to show me
what it's like to live out here
[Music]
i'm here to learn the unique survival
skills of the samburu
i have 10 days to master the techniques
they've honed over centuries
before i take on the ultimate challenge
an extreme multi-day cattle drive to
deliver famished cows to essential new
pastures
going through one of the most hostile
environments in the world
my mentor while i'm here will be kasana
he is one of the samburu elite
who take on the vital responsibility of
protecting the community's livestock
i start immersing myself in tribal life
by dressing in a traditional ashuka
kasana then sets my first task
identifying dangerous animals that have
come close to the village perimeter
the samburu share their home with some
of the most deadly creatures on the
planet
they are prepared for attack at all
times
and routinely scout for signs of danger
in the area
straight away i come across some fresh
tracks
you can just barely make it out there's
the main paw the toe and prince
a little bit of claw it's a hyena track
these predators prey on the samburu's
livestock
but can also attack and kill humans
[Music]
hyenas for these people are one of the
most dangerous animals
it's not just tooth and claw that i have
to be on high alert for
this is a track that's really easy to
spot
right there that's an elephant track
these are the largest land mammals on
earth and can bulldoze anything that
gets in their way
these guys live right next door to some
dangerous dangerous animals
the samburu's main concern isn't humans
being attacked
but they're precious cattle whose
importance permeates
every level of tribal life here
not only can they provide all their food
but they're also marriage dowries
and an elder's wealth is determined by
the size of his herd
it's their grocery store and life
savings
but above all it gives them status
within the tribe
next i have to take some of these
precious cows to water
directly through predator territory
it's the end of the dry season and water
is at its most scarce
the nearest functioning well is an hour
away take this one
okay let's get big horns
i'm a novice at herding so kasana has
started me off small
with five cows
hurting is a basic skill i've got to
master
otherwise i'll be a liability on the
final challenge of the cattle drive
to get the herd to go left you come in
from the right and vice versa
it's not rocket science but simple
things aren't always easy
it's already hard work keeping up with
these guys they want to get to water
[Music]
there's a lot of running around that in
this heat is sapping my energy and
fluids quickly
dehydration in these conditions can have
dangerous effects
i can understand these cows are very
lean
there's no fat on them like american
cows
after an hour we reach the well it's the
only water source in the area
so will also be a draw for any local
predators
kasana is satisfied that i can handle a
small herd
but that was just the first test
my fluid levels are low but the priority
now
is to get water for the cows
i'll have to wait
[Music]
this well has been dug straight into the
sand with no supporting structure
and it regularly collapses these sides
are so
unstable here we go
these walls just keep caving in on us
cows need a lot of water and getting it
out of the ground
and up to the trough is serious physical
[Music]
work
on the final challenge getting water is
going to be a huge task
there will be a much larger herd to deal
with and no
permanent wells along the trail
[Music]
in this arid landscape using as little
water as possible
is a key survival strategy
it's embedded in samburu life
and my host mother shows me how the
village women clean their kitchenware
without water put some of the charcoal
in there
they shake it around
[Music]
this is how they clean their dishes
cleanliness is important here in these
temperatures
food spoils rapidly and whenever
possible
it's consumed fresh
like the samburu superfood cow's blood
packed full of protein this is an
important part of the warriors diet
and is drunk straight from the cow but
collecting it
requires a steady hand and a sure shot
this is a very special arrow tip
it's only meant to go that deep just
through the skin and penetrate one side
of the jugular
that's got to be precise if you don't do
it in the right spot
you're in the risk of killing one of the
cows
killing a cow here would take away a
vital food source
and deprive the samburu of their most
valuable asset
that would probably be the worst thing i
could possibly do here
okay kasana has selected our donor
now to catch a cow
a tourniquet is tied around the cow's
neck
constricting the blood flow brings the
veins to the surface of the skin
making a clearer target
[Music]
i've got to fire the arrow point blank
and with the precise amount of force
cause sonnet tells me the cow will feel
a little pain
but i'm uncomfortable doing this
i don't want to mess nervous
i've got to stay focused and hold my
nerve
time to go for the jugular
i didn't fire with enough force
[Music]
this is my last chance casano marks out
exactly where i have to hit
[Music]
i haven't succeeded this time it's
turned out to be much harder than i
thought
but this is a skill i've got to master
because it will be essential on the
cattle drive
[Music]
cassano shows me how it's done
you know i i made multiple attempts
on the neck of this poor cow i wasn't
getting the jugular
the samburu might take two pints of
blood at a time
[Music]
then the wound is pinched shut
no band-aid needed here this cow will be
good as new
and a relatively short amount of time
finally a handful of sand is used to
help seal the wound
and the cow is fine as for me
things are about to get uncomfortable
i'm going to have to drink the blood but
once it's exposed to air
it starts to solidify with vigorous
stirring
the coagulant collects on the stick and
can be removed
so the rest is liquid and then there's
just the
coagulated blood evidently
they feed this to the dog
it's time to drink this is a totally new
experience for me
and i know there's a genuine risk of
illness
the first sip was hard to keep down but
each one after that gets slightly easier
this is going to take some getting used
to
[Music]
now for the second course a samburu
smoothie
blood mixed with milk
it tastes a lot better
tastes more like milk and hint of blood
warriors have lived off of only blood
and milk for months at a time
and for the rest of my stay here this
will be my diet
lunch break over it's time to get back
to work
deadly wildlife is a constant threat
and the tribe has built a ring of thorns
around the village to protect humans and
livestock alike
legiora the patriarch of the family i'm
staying with
shows me how to maintain this vital
defense
this stuff is pretty incredible
it's like nature's barbed wire you look
at these thorns
spikes like this will keep the cattle in
and hopefully
the animals that want to eat them out
they're almost impossible to handle so
some buru
have a tool for the job this is an
interesting stick
specially made to mend these fences it
has a
way to tuck in
those branches and then it has a hook to
grab
anything you can do to keep your fragile
fingers away from those huge thorns
on the cattle drive i'll build a thorn
fence like this from scratch
during the night it will be the only
thing standing between me
and the deadly wild animals
just outside the village there's a
shocking reminder of what the defenses
are made to keep out
we're called to a leopard kill that
happened within the last couple of hours
one of the girls of the village was
hurting about 40
goats and all of a sudden a leopard
pounced out of the bush
took down one of her goats she got
really scared she was terrified
she ran back to the village to tell the
elders and here they are
these big cats easily pick off livestock
and even though it's rare
some have become man-eaters
[Music]
this is quite a reality check these
hills
are filled with lethal predators and i'm
going to be out
here spending the night with my
livestock
and i run the risk of winding up like
this poor goat
at dusk the whole community in their
livestock retreat behind the safety of
the thorn fence
i bed down in my host family's hut
it's my first experience being in a
place like this where
you look outside and there's tracks of
hyena and leopard
elephant and then you go inside the
thorn fence and then you get to be here
in the safety of your village and
feels pretty nice actually
sleep is a survival necessity that is
often overlooked
[Music]
not getting enough makes it harder to
think clearly
which could be life-threatening in this
hostile environment
but the time to get valuable rest is
when the most dangerous predators come
out to hunt
searching for easy prey
[Music]
disturbances have to be confronted head
on
predators might have breached the
defenses
the warriors only concern is to fight
off whatever might be attacking them big
surprise to me
they just all woke up all of a sudden i
didn't know what's going on i just
followed them and then
they're all running it was pitch black i
figured something was going on with the
cattle
it seems to be a false alarm but it
shows kasana
how i'd react in the event of an attack
on the cattle drive
when these attacks happen you have to be
there
on the spot right away okay
let's get back to bed
this has been an important lesson from
now on
i'll have to be on high alert
[Music]
the samburu traditionally don't grow
anything
taking great pride in how their
livestock can provide everything they
need
but there's one wild food they'll always
forage for
honey
kassana is taking us to a hive he
recently discovered
like most things in nature it's not
place for our convenience
it's more than 25 feet up a tree right
there
is a dead palm tree and i can just
barely see the swarm of bees
flying into a hole we have to be on our
guard
the moment the bees sense that the hive
is under threat they'll attack
smoke helps to subdue them so before we
do anything
a fire has to be started
everything here is bone dry and the
tinder catches first time
yeah yeah wow we've got a fire
protective measures in place we can
start to chop the tree down
but it's not going to come easily
once the tree's fallen all that stands
between us and the honey
is a swarm of angry african bees
when a bee stings it releases an alarm
pheromone
when other bees detect this they go into
a defensive frenzy
but they're stinging me
the others are getting stung as much as
me but they aren't showing
any reaction to the pain
away from the angry bees i finally get
to taste the honey
oh my god never has honey
ever tasted this amazing especially
considering i've been on a diet
of only milk and blood this is like
with every bite it feels like like
the sugar's just penetrating the cells
as if
my body has been so needing this
returning to the village with our bounty
is a happy occasion
everybody has just found their piece and
they're running off with it so they can
enjoy it all to themselves
[Music]
but it's not long before i'm back on my
warrior diet
this is dinner it's been sitting out all
day
in the warm kenyan day and the fats
have sat on top
there's like a big floating scab and top
[Music]
a new day and a new lesson yesterday
i thought it was okay to react to the
bee stings
but kasana is concerned because some
guru warriors do not show pain
in this dangerous environment it's a
distraction they can't afford
because wants to get me into a warrior
frame of mind
thousands of ants are coming out ah
they're like fire ants
these ants are small but they can sure
pack a punch
it's like a cigarette burn ah kasana and
the junior warriors are also getting
stung
but once again they aren't showing any
reaction to the pain
i'm just trying not to feel them
crawling all over me
and i'm just absolutely trying to
dissolve
the feeling of this burning that's all
over my back right now
if i'm gonna deal with pain here i've
got to keep it to myself
i can feel one going right into my eye
total concentration
the true samburu warrior deals with all
hardships
in silence they are never supposed to
show
how hungry they are how tired they are
these guys just have to maintain a stoic
lifestyle
it's all about keeping complete focus on
protecting the cows at all costs it's a
state of mind
that i'll have to adopt on the cattle
drive otherwise
i'll be putting the cows the samburu
depend on in danger
i proved i can handle the pain but so
far
i failed to master collecting the
samburu superfood
blood kasana is letting me have one
final attempt
the jugular's exposed now
here we go again if i fail this time
my future as a blood warrior will be
under threat
this is my last chance to prove that i
can get blood from a cow
they're so happy that i finally got this
they are so happy for me
jump jump okay little bit of sand
it feels good these guys have a lot more
confidence in me now
never has warm blood and milk tasted so
good
this is a breakthrough for a samburu
warrior
the ability to live off a cow is the key
to self-sufficiency in the bush
i'm almost ready for the cattle drive
there's just one last skill to master
how to defend
against attacking animals
my host father le hora is showing me how
to make a samburu club
back home i do a lot of work with wood
i know how important it is to get the
right piece for the job
legera has scouted out the perfect tree
for what we need
this wood that he's chosen he
is really hard okay
yeah that would probably do some damage
this big stick is going to turn into
something like this
the warriors carry these with them every
day wherever they go
and when push comes to shove these are
[Music]
lethal
after hours of patient carving it's
ready to be put through its paces
first and foremost it's an offensive
weapon
capable of killing any attacking animal
it also has a secondary defensive use
this is used to throw with accuracy into
a herd of say
elephants it scares them away and keeps
us all safe and that's what i'm gonna
learn to do now
kasana shows me how it's done using a
tree
about a hundred feet away as a target
damn i can't believe the accuracy of
these guys have
penalty i'm way off target
because sana quickly spots where i'm
going wrong
i'm not holding it in the right way so
that there
okay
the new grip has drastically improved my
accuracy
[Music]
i don't want to have to use it but this
powerful skill could mean the difference
between
life and death when defending against
wild animals in the bush
i'm now equipped with all the skills
needed for the cattle drive
this is going to be like nothing i've
done before
it's not just about keeping myself alive
but also an entire herd of valuable cows
tomorrow is the day kasana has decided
that i should eat my first
solid food in a week giving me a vital
energy boost
the samburu slaughter their highly
prized cows rarely
but for goats it's a different story
and this is not gonna be your everyday
barbecue
apparently what they do before we eat
the meat of this goat is
they drink the blood of the goat first
i'll be doing the drinking direct from
the dying animal
the goat has its throat slit you can see
the jugular
right there oh my god a cup is made from
a flap of neck skinny
[Music]
i don't know how much more blood i
[Music]
but what's left is just blood jello
this is what they do they've been doing
this their entire lives this is uh
this is samburu life and it's no big
deal
to me this is a huge deal
that was way outside my comfort zone and
a giant step into the world of the
samburu warrior i have left my western
inhibitions behind
and embraced the traditions of the tribe
and after the ritual the reward
these guys are making such short work of
this goat
so they've partitioned all the meat now
all these meat go to certain individuals
from the elders getting the head to the
married women of the village getting the
entrails
every group in the highly ordered
samburu society
gets a specific part of the goat
the warriors get the best cuts the ribs
and hind legs
that we cook up immediately
ribs are the first thing to be done
look at that sweet tasty juicy ribs
this is my first solid food in a week
after my blood and milk diet it's one of
the tastiest meals i've ever had
i'm so good
with a full stomach my body feels
prepared for tomorrow's big cattle drive
but my mind is full of uncertainties
i'm just trying to think about what it's
going to be like
it's uncharted territory for me and out
there
i don't know where water is i don't have
the safety of my village
and
that's reality
it's early morning on the first day of
the cattle drive
nearly all grazing around the village
has been exhausted
it's vital i get these cows to new
pasture
the village elders have gathered to
discuss what i'm doing
i originally thought that i was just
taking my my host father's cows
but all these villagers say that
i take their cows as well this is
a much bigger challenge than i had
thought
i can't mess this up these cattle mean
too much to these people
actually
kasana tells me the exact size the herd
is going to be
we're going to be taking 70 cows out on
this trek
that's a lot of cows 70 chances of
things to go wrong
it's humbling that the elders trust me
this much
but it's a huge step up i was only
dealing with five
cows before the herd includes calves
vulnerable to dehydration and easy
pickings for predators in the bush
kassana has told me that it's going to
be a two-day trek through hazardous
terrain
we'll be surrounded by killer wildlife
and exposed to the elements
the final test will be a perilous climb
into the mountains
where good grazing can still be found
here i'll hand over the cows to a relief
team of warriors
there's one final bombshell kasana
what was going to be a test has now
become a trial
a large herd needs more than one person
to move them
so i'm joined by the junior warriors
i've been training with
otayo and lesian
you know i haven't had one of these yet
but it's pretty self-explanatory
we are taking no food or drink with us
the cows will provide all of our
sustenance
and water will have to be dug out along
the way
there's just time for a goodbye from
kasana
and my host father
[Music]
my final challenge has begun
not turning back now it's early morning
and it's already hot the temperature is
only going to climb from here
being in the back here mostly it's just
dusty the cows walk with a brisk pace
and to collect strays i have to run
around
in this heat the extra exertion is
rapidly depleting my water reserves
i find this hard work even just to keep
up with the cows
at this pace it's still morning
the heat of the day hasn't really shown
up yet
it's mostly thick scrub here and the
best route to take
is the clear dried out riverbeds
the samburu say leopards could be lying
in wait
shrouded by the bushes we have to be
cautious
now we're in this area with a bunch of
dense
vegetation a perfect place for one of
these calves to be picked off
[Music]
it's the hottest part of the day now and
none of us can go on much longer if we
can't find water
i'm really suffering from fluid loss but
i must adopt the warrior way
and stay focused the more fragile calves
are at serious risk of dying from
dehydration
fortunately nature leaves clues for
where to start looking for a drink
this kind of plant means that there's
water right here
hit bedrock but right before you hit
bedrock
see all that sand how it sticks to the
tip
that's all water
while the junior warriors protect the
cattle i dig down to the water
[Music]
different types of sand can hold
enormous amounts of water
[Music]
oh my god water
kasana would not be impressed to see me
drinking before the cows
but i'm desperate
now i can continue digging to make sure
the cows get their share
clearly other herders have dug here
before us
nearby we find an old discarded trough
for the cattle to drink from
once the cows have had their fill we
carry on until near sunset
[Music]
our grueling day isn't over yet
we still have to make camp where are you
spending the night right here
to protect ourselves from wild animals
we're going to build a version of the
thorn fence that surrounds the village
this is a nice open area but we're going
to utilize what's already existing to
our advantage
it'll be a circular corral these walls
will all be
thorny shrubs this center circle that's
where we'll put the calves
we'll sleep alongside the cattle and
then this right here
this is the one opening that we'll have
to this entire
structure that we're going to build time
to get to work
[Music]
with our defenses complete matayo and i
have put our tracking skills to use
looking for signs of dangerous animals
nearby
baboons are calling i'm up in the hills
it's not unheard of for troops of
baboons to seriously injure humans
or rip apart livestock
it's kind of spooky then
the tracks we'd feared those are leopard
tracks
from today i've already seen how bold
they can be
when picking off livestock
those tracks may be of a leopard that's
stalking our cattle right now
we just have to hope the thorn fence
does its job through the night
time to try and rest
this is bad and to top it off
this is our pillow
and i'm perfectly fine with it
i'm ready to collapse but i have to be
on my guard for any potential attacks
this is when the cattle are at their
most vulnerable
[Music]
tonight we're gonna sleep with one eye
closed and one eye open
we have to listen to the cows and if any
sign of danger we have to wake up
and we have to respond immediately
we're all exhausted but i'm too on edge
about what could be out there to sleep
for long
as we're all sleeping here
there's mataya fast asleep
see one
[Music]
you just wake up all of a sudden because
these cows they just start
running in the corral and you're
sleeping on the ground
you just have to jump up and get out of
the way before you even know what's
going on because
you're in the risk of all these cows
just stampeding you
it's freaky
there is something out there and the
cattle refuse to settle for the rest of
the night
there will be little sleep now before
dawn
at first light what could have been
scaring the herd reveals itself
it was just snooping around the corral
i just woke up and there was a hyena
just staring
right at us
it's a little bit unnerving the cattle
are safe
and we've made it through the night but
the toughest part of the journey is yet
to come
i said mataio points out our ultimate
destination
we're gonna be taking these cattle up to
the top of that mountain
yesterday was tough but getting 70 cows
up a mountain
is taking it to another level
the fragile calves are on the edge
[Music]
the extra exertion of climbing could
finish them off
but they have to get up to the new
pasture
from here we're just trying to find the
best route
to get up onto that ridge if we choose a
bad route
we run the risk of taking up all these
cattle up something steep
it could be really difficult getting
these things off that mountain
this is the crux of the challenge it
looks like an impossible task
but there's no turning back now some of
the cattle would never make it back to
the village
we have to press on we're definitely
in the climb now
it's the final hurdle but i can't let my
guard down for a moment
we're still in leopard ambush territory
[Music]
if an attack happens now i will be
expected to defend the cows with my life
and in this landscape that's going to be
no easy task
everything is covered with thorns every
step you take rock rolls out from under
your feet
you're getting tangled up scratched up
snagged
some of the most unpalatable train i've
ever been in
after hours of tough climbing i finally
see the warriors that i'm handing the
herd over to
we've made it spot yes
somebody here comes yeah
they just asked if all of our cows made
it up here
yes indeed they did they're all up here
they're all grazing now and they are
happy
bringing the herd up to vital new
pastures has been a tough but rewarding
journey of discovery
the samburu survive in one of the most
inhospitable places on earth because of
one thing
their cattle
of the skills i've learned have equipped
me to keep these cows alive
and in return they've been my complete
survival package
i make the journey back to the village
bringing news to the elders that all
their precious cattle
made it safely up to the new pastors
that was a test of my endurance that i
will have with me my entire life
it feels so good to be back and to see
all these smiling faces
they know that i went through a lot
after my host father last to
congratulate me
is my mentor
seeing how pleased he is it's clear i've
survived the tribe
but more than that i feel i've become a
blood warrior
[Music]
you